if you had a friend and every single
time that you and your friend decided
that you're going to go out for dinner
that friend either showed up two hours
late or didn't show up at all you would
stop trusting that person that is the
relationship that you have with yourself
you need to be able to trust your own
word and a lot of us don't because life
is very convenient it is easy for people
to not stick to the promises that they
set themselves because our ability to be
idealistic always going to outstrip
reality's ability to deliver that to us
as soon as you posit an ideal you then
begin to compare yourself to that ideal
and true hell is when the person that
you are meets the person that you could
have been